when you went on Rogan he wanted to
refer you to stem cells for the last two
years I've been getting stem cells and
it's been the best thing that has ever
happened to me in my life really yeah
but you gotta go out of this country to
do it because they don't ever really
allow the real stem cells that comes
from the placenta you know yeah they
don't allow that here in the United
States because politics what exactly is
stem cells so my understanding is that
we're like blank cells they can
transform to anything you surround
themselves with they'll turn into that
so if you inject them in your leg
they'll turn into leg cells it wipes out
the pain I go through because I have a
herniated disc and my upper back still
as soon as I get the stem cell the
injection it completely goes away and
how much is it 2 800 per injection where
do you go Puerto Vallarta Mexico